[Música]
era pequeña una de mis películas
favoritas
me gustaba la idea de estar preparada
para todo y un momento donde
donde yo sentía que ya no tenía el
control de las cosas
y ese fue el momento
en el que estaba a punto de graduarme mi
carrera de Licenciatura y qué
licenciatura tengo pues en Zathura en la
carrera más inútil en la carrera que
toda la gente cuando cuando llega su
hijo o su hija y le dice sí quiero
estudiar
yo soy licenciada en Literatura
encierro y mucha gente cuando yo dije
que ese quería que fuera mi futuro me
hizo bullying se burlo de mí me dijo que
no iba a encontrar un futuro y me hizo
sentirme totalmente desprotegida
insegura y poco preparada
y es que para empezar
qué cita natura es una definición que da
la recuerda son 8 definiciones los queda
la RAE
incluyendo una que dice palabrería
y está bien la verdadera pregunta es
para qué sirve un literato eso que está
empezando todos ustedes
bueno si vamos a la definición que varía
el lado técnico la persona que conserva
preserva y divulga conocimiento arte y
entretenimiento
si vamos a la definición de que
realmente así hemos visto pañero de
carrera y yo la persona que decir para
un salario insostenible en fotocopias
libros usados y alicientes para la
depresión
entonces estaba yo a punto de pasar a mí
extraño
en la carrera donde más me he sentido
enamorada porque yo he estado más feliz
cuando he estado con los
en los libros más gruesos en los libros
más viejos en los más desgastados porque
yo soñaba con ser un escritor con
impactar con esas historias que nos
llevan a imaginar lugares lejanos a
imaginar un futuro y con esas historias
de esas que no se toma un minuto leerlas
yo quiero pasar mejor así será feliz
pasando horas en la Biblioteca
escribiendo leyendo y por qué no me
merecía un futuro con eso
porque no merecía todas las burlas y
numeración futuro yo veía a mis
compañeros terminando en carreras peores
terminando en carreras donde les dicen
bueno para ti para qué para qué para
terminar en un call center para terminar
de freelancer para terminar de mesera en
alguna parte
y la respuesta de todo será lo que pasa
es que lo que aprendiste no sirve para
nada
muchísimas gracias entonces
no pudo regresar a hacer otra carrera no
puedo rehacer mi vida no existen las
dinámicas de viaje en el tiempo pero
puedo empezar a pensar porque existe lo
que yo estudio porque existe la
literatura y es curioso porque vengo de
un país
donde hay un premio Nobel de Literatura
hay solo se hizo en Latinoamérica uno de
esos está aquí en Guatemala y un estaría
pensando que estamos nadando en
escritores estamos nadando en poetas
porque la literatura democratiza el
desarrollo de un país tal vez no tenemos
grandes científicos tal vez tenemos una
economía frágil pero tenemos la
capacidad de hacer arte que nos pone en
los mejores lugares del mundo
porque porque entonces nos burlamos
cuando la gente dice quiero al gato
quiero ser escritor porque lo que
pensamos así un escritor con sus lentes
o removido de la realidad ni siquiera
con una pantalla porque los libros
electrónicos no son lo mismo
cuál es la verdadera función de un
escritor
realmente tenía que preguntarme
un escrito para qué sirve para que no se
sienta a escribir grandes novelas
pues ahí fue donde llegue a esta pequeña
conclusión
los escritores deben aprender está y por
favor no me pidan que baile porque me
suba a ser catastrófico me refiero a
quien tienen un texto cuál es la tarea
cuál es la audiencia y cuál es su
propósito porque ningún buen texto sale
sin que uno considere estos tres
factores que estoy haciendo para quién
lo estoy haciendo y para quién lo estoy
haciendo
eso está importancia de integrar un
mensaje y iPhone donde entendí que esto
eso que debo aplicar en la manera de
entender una carrera y en la manera de
entender una filosofía de vida la verdad
porque nos enseñan que las carreras son
como los moldes de galletas
te van a cortar como un abogado y toda
la vida vas a ser un abogado te van a
cortar como un ingeniero toda la vida
vas a ser un ingeniero te van a cortar
como un escritor y
telas el metro
y de hecho me fui dando cuenta de este
gran viaje cuando empecé a analizar todo
lo que la gente me dijo
emojis esta carrera porque escribir es
fácil y no te del cerebro para la mate
muchas gracias Alejandro
está bien eso es una excusa constante
para la gente de las humanidades pero no
sé
algunos de los trabajos que he tenido
porque deje de pensar en la carrera como
una forma el imitación y más como un set
de destrezas porque entonces puedo o
puedo abrirme la cabeza y puedo hacer
cualquiera de estas cosas y perseveran
en ello no tengo un solo día aburrido
por eso
aunque te vuelvas una escritora nadie te
va a contratar y vas a morirte de hambre
muchas gracias profe Javier
porque tenemos hasta ganas de motivar a
la gente es frío pero de nuevo pensé hay
una audiencia para esto hay una
audiencia que le interesa que tienen en
común los brontosaurios y las Barbies no
sé yo lo voy a encontrar que voy a
generar ese contenido y si alguna
persona dice que no tienes posibilidad
de lograrlo en las humanidades 30 días
es el máximo de tiempo que he estado
desempleada después de haberme graduado
después de haber confiado en mis propias
capacidades y de cerrarme a la idea de
que las humanidades no sirven y la única
razón por la que estuve trabajando
porque estuve viajando a Europa a
Sudamérica a compartir con otras
personas que entienden el valor de las
historias que entienden el valor de
reconocer nuestro pasado y de crear de
crear con la ficción porque es una forma
en la que nos entendemos y ahí es donde
encontrado mi audiencia donde personas
que creen en la capacidad transformadora
de la literatura la capacidad
transformadora de lenguaje
la que más duele que es la de mi familia
esa carrera solo te va a meter ideas de
margaritas en la cabeza no sirve para
nada
muchas gracias
a lo largo de mi carrera he escrito 210
artículos originales en diferentes
revistas iberoamericanas he hablado he
hablado
la capacidad de conectarnos un rato y
jugar con acidez y si
acumule muchísimos conocimientos
conocimientos en literatura son con todo
el contenido de esta bolsa bastantes
cosas bastante disparejas
alguna tiene
cada una tiene algo que podemos hacer
con ellos y cada una tiene una audiencia
que le corresponde así que he tenido el
sueño que no me imaginé es distinto a lo
que yo había esperado y he esperado
convertirme en escritura pero he tenido
un viaje aún más grande que he hecho si
también incluye que me haya convertido
en escritura entonces
yo estoy yo se lo que dicen que está
bien lo que aprendiste no sirve para
nada y eso me pasó con eso porque está
bien nada sirve para todo pero
definitivamente todo sirve para anto
y por eso estoy orgullosa de todo lo que
llevo aquí todo lo que me acompaña todo
lo que contar esas historias a formar
esas ideas y a llevar esa comunicación
tan importante que traen las humanidades
aún si tenemos que empezar a pensar las
desde cero a pelotear las ideas
lo que quiero es que nunca se dejen
pensar que las humanidades son una forma
de olvidar a la gente solo contrario es
un puente para que nos comuniquemos
mejor y para que entendamos que el mundo
puede puede cambiar pero necesitamos
esto necesitamos llevar el lado humano y
llevarlo bajo nuestro control muchísimas
gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]